we felt the risk idea was so obvious
that every all the major industries will
pick it up and trample is underfoot
what was surprising was that it took the
major companies a very long time to even
think risk was worth considering and and
so we got at least a five-year headstart
over them so we got this process so and
we thought well that works rather nicely
it's quite cheap we can just make these
and put them in our desktop products we
thought well actually this works
efficiently well it would be quite nice
if we found some other uses and we did
license it to VLSI technology in 1987
and interestingly it found its way into
a radius graphics accelerator for the
Apple machines Apple - I think it was so
Apple started using arm through
indirectly much earlier than they
thought but we never really thought we
were competing with the big boys we just
thought we had a niche that we could
possibly slide through and when Apple
came knocking on the door that which was
actually after I left acorn I left acorn
in August 92 come to Manchester and it
must have been a month or two after that
Apple came knocking and saying we have
this Newton product we've been working
with the AT&T Hobbit but actually we
think the arm is better suited but we're
not that happy with the arm being owned
by a competitor how about we set this up
as a joint venture and of course they
were knocking on open door
acorn had been trying for a couple of
years to offload the overhead of
supporting arm development from his own
product sales and so the company was up
and running in soif and baalbek by
november which is a remarkable rate of
progress even then the people that
formed arm and Robin Saxby was brought
in to lead it but the people that formed
the core team with the people who I'd
worked with at acorn and they were all
nervously laughing about you know
Saxbys vision of world domination
I mean Robin was firmly the view that
you had to think this was going to be a
global standard because that was the
only way you could succeed in processes
you either take the world by storm or
you disappear but I think it was quite
some time before even his own colleagues
started to buy into this view one of the
interesting observations of course is
that although we now think of Newton as
a failure it is the Newton that made arm
because then as now the Apple brand was
about the biggest brand in the business
and on was supplying Apple and therefore
that opened all sorts of doors
they got licensees signing up almost
queuing up just because of the Apple
name and by the time it was beginning to
become clear that Newton was not going
to succeed
it didn't matter so much but for the
first few years of army was crucial in
95 they got the Nokia business and
through Texas Instruments I think and
you know since then they've never looked
back Nokia with the biggest name of the
biggest brand so impose on Nokia was by
far the biggest brand in in mobile phone
handsets in the mid-90s and getting that
brand basically and you will make now
this is not to say that that the company
hasn't had to work very diligently at
maintaining and improving that position
and mobile phones are not everything
they sell in fact I think only half the
the the 12 billion arm shipped in the
last year went into mobile phones so
that means six billion went somewhere
else thanks to Squarespace com for
sponsoring this episode of computer Val
and if you go over to Squarespace comm
slash computer file slash computer file
you can build a website with they're
easy to use and very intuitive tools
they've got state-of-the-art technology
which ensures stability and security and
computer files might want to check out
their developers platform at developers
Squarespace comm you can start building
that website today without
entering any credit card details and
when you do make your first purchase if
you use the offer code computer file
you'll get 10% off so thanks once again
to Squarespace for sponsoring this
computer of our video the company that
was running most parallel to the risk
thinking was actually in Moss in Bristol
with the transputer now if you look at
the philosophy behind the transputer
simplicity is RIT very large but their
approach to simplicity was different
from RISC the transmuter is not inspired
or influenced by risk in the way that
risk was arms middle-name when it was
the Acorn RISC machine